So many actors were almost cast in the
Harry Potter series that we could have
had a completely different franchise can
you imagine Robin Williams as Hagrid or
watching Hugh Grant in the Chamber of
Secrets let's talk about it Tilda
Swinton was considered for the role of
Professor Sybil trilani it seems she'd
be an obvious choice to put in the Harry
Potter world because of her eccentric
style and incredible acting skills when
she first turned down the role she said
it was for scheduling conflicts later
down the line the truth ended up coming
out she highly dislikes boarding schools
and the isolation they inflict on kids
she actually said they were a cruel
place to grow up and just couldn't get
behind romanticizing such a place Tim
Roth has played some Stellar roles with
many of them being antagonists in movies
like Pulp Fiction Selma and the hateful
eight obviously with all that under his
belt it's clear that he'd be one of the
first choices for Severus Snape Tim was
super interested in the role and almost
signed up for it then and there but
unfortunately he was also interested in
Tim Burton's Planet of the Apes remake
he even tried to make both roles work
and create some super intense work
schedule ultimately though he just
didn't have enough time in the day and
ended up filming the Planet of the Apes
remake and passing on defense against
the dark arts this one I could totally
see Hugh Grant was offered the role of
gilderoy Lockhart he eventually actively
sought out the role and was always the
first choice for it even since his first
round of auditions unfortunately Hugh
Grant ended up turning down the role due
to some scheduling conflicts so the
producers ended up going with Kenneth
Branagh who truly did play the iconic
Chamber of Secrets character perfectly
still I'm always curious about how the
character would have changed if a
different actor were to step in their
shoes Naomi Watts auditioned for the
role of Narcissa Malfoy the role really
needed a seasoned actor Narcissa Draco
Malfoy's mother has a chilling presence
that only someone really talented could
portray well the producers didn't want
to cast just anyone on they were truly
on the lookout for the perfect English
actor to portray the character obviously
Naomi Watts came up in conversation
interestingly enough Naomi never even
knew she was in the running for her her
agent turned down the role on her behalf
Ian McAllen was offered the role of
Albus Dumbledore after Richard Harris
passed away partly because he seemed
like an obvious choice after his iconic
portrayal of the other legendary Wizard
Gandalf in The Lord of the Rings he's
also an incredible actor having won a
ton of major Awards a Golden Globe
Lawrence Olivier Awards and like
numerous Oscar Noms so why did he turn
it down you ask well Richard Harris had
a bit of a part in that Richard just
didn't like Ian as an actor so Ian
didn't feel right about taking his role
after he passed away because he knew
that Robin Williams was super into the
idea of playing the role of Hagrid but
was turned down as JK Rowling's had
specified that all actors in the film
should be British technically it wasn't
his decision but I truly can't believe
Robin Williams could have been a major
role in Harry Potter would you be
absolutely shocked if you saw Michael
Cera in a Harry Potter movie well that
might have not been too crazy to imagine
he almost signed a deal to Star and
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them
and when it came to the actual Harry
Potter series American actors basically
had to go on home because every actor
had to actually be English in real life
but when Fantastic Beasts got into the
picture they were able to actually
audition for it Michael was offered the
role of Jacob Kowalski Michael actually
really wanted to do the role but he had
a scheduling conflict with another role
he was given in the Lego Batman movie he
ended up taking the role in The Lego
Movie and gave up his role to Dan
foldler at the end of the series when
trying to cast Helena Ravenclaw Kate
Winslet was always the first choice
Helena Ravenclaw played a major role in
helping bring down Lord Voldemort so it
was important she had a lasting presence
on screen similar to how things went
with Naomi Watts Kate Winslet's agent
also rejected the role on her behalf
Kate never even got out the chance to
consider it Christopher Lee has a ton of
major roles under his belt including
Saruman and the Lord of the Rings and
Count Dooku in the Star Wars prequels
are you surprised to find out Harry
Potter was also on that long list of
achievements as well he was another
actor who was considered to take over
for Richard Harris as Dumbledore But
ultimately ended up turning it down
because of the unsettling gossip that
was around the casting for the role
can't say I blame him for that one were
you shocked at the Harry Potter series
that almost was now every time I see
Hagrid or Narcissa Malfoy I'll always
try and picture Robin Williams or Naomi
Watts who would you be most excited to
see in Harry Potter